How do I answer this
when there's puppies
running all over on me?
(jingle bells)
Hi.
(upbeat rock music)
What are you talking about?
Santa comes every year.
Even the dogs are at odds about this.
Can't control them, they
just do what they want.
Everything about the
holidays is just so much fun
that I don't even know how to explain it
while I'm watching these
puppies fight with each other.
They're so adorable, I
can't believe they're here.
I'll be happy with anything,
it's the thought that counts.
Awe. Come on.
It's the cutest thing ever.
Look, they're too young to be trained,
so this is a natural moment.
All I want for Christmas is my...
The first Christmas song that I ever wrote
for my first Christmas album,
which is called 'Merry Christmas',
and there's a new animated movie
about a little girl that
wants a puppy for Christmas.
Ouch. This one bites.
I'm just here posing and
playing with puppies,
talking about other things,
but to answer your question,
but, wait...
Soon as I get back in the
studio after Christmas,
because right now we're celebrating
the fact that we have a...
Look at this dog, come on.
I wasn't thinking about that,
I was just recording a Christmas song.
Hi, puppy.
That's a boring answer,
but it's the truth.
Look at this, please tell
me you're getting this.
Adorable.
Buzzfeed.
- [Woman] I knew it.
(upbeat music)